we've already detected dark matter we've
already seen its effects here on earth
and in the heavens itself but what if i
told you dark matter has been a mystery
in physics for over 70 years in this
episode we're taking a deep dive into
the one form of dark matter that we know
100 exists into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
dark matter is fascinating it continues
to mystify and tantalize astronomers
physicists cosmologists and more to this
very day today we're going to take a
deep dive into one particular form of
dark matter that we know beyond a shadow
of a doubt actually exists to learn
about the unknown first study the known
as well as you possibly can i like to
give an analogy based on the following
joke there's a cop a policeman and he's
looking around and he sees a drunk guy
on his hands and knees looking for
something underneath a street light he
says to the drunk guy what'd you lose
the drunk guy says ah i lost my keys
so they both start looking under the
lamp post until the policeman says are
you sure you lost them here the drunk
says no
i lost him in the park so the cop says
why are you looking here
and the drunk says this is where the
light is it's not so silly a strategy
and in fact i think it's one that we can
pursue in order to reveal the properties
of dark matter more fully today we can
employ this strategy not to look for
things in the light but to look for
things that are dark for decades a
similar type of strategy to this drunk
guy has been employed both by drunks and
by neutrino hunters
so far they've had no keys in sight and
only obtained a few key insights in 1916
einstein published the second of his
general relativity papers
100 years later using einstein's
predictions we are at the precipice of
weighing the last elementary particle
whose mass is unknown isn't this old
news don't we know all the fundamental
particle masses already after measuring
the higgs boson's mass
well yes and not
looking at the standard model we see 16
massive particles quarks we also see
leptons like the electron
and bosons such as the photon and the
higgs boson
and they're all charted together in a
table that's reminiscent of mendelev's
periodic table of the elements except in
the case of the quarks bosons and
leptons on the table there are no
periods observable there's no apparent
ordering at work here
three of the six so-called leptons and
lepton means small in greek these are
particles that don't participate in the
strong nuclear force these leptons have
three generations we also see three
generations of neutrinos the electron
muon and town neutrinos and as integral
as they are to the foundations of matter
we are in the dark about their masses
the neutrino masses now a particle's
mass is arguably its most important
property so this lacuna is rightfully
seen as an embarrassment for physics and
for physicists but this is about to
change neutrinos change their flavor
their generation from one flavor to
another as they propagate through the
cosmos this phenomenon is called
oscillation and the 2015 nobel prize in
physics went to vegeta and mcdonald for
the discovery of neutrino oscillations
showing that neutrinos have mass not
only do we know neutrinos have mass
their work gives us a lower limit on
their masses
at least one of the three neutrinos must
have a mass bigger than that of about
one twentieth of an electron volt
physicists use einstein's relationship e
equals m c squared to convert masses
into equivalent energies the next
heaviest elementary particle is the
electron whose mass is 10 million times
larger than that lower limit
most importantly these lower limits of
neutrino masses give us experimentalist
thresholds to target
all that's left is to build a scale to
weigh these wistful ghostly particles
neutrinos are generated in nuclear
reactions such as fusion and radioactive
decay the ultimate reactor of course was
the biggest cauldron of them all the big
bad like light neutrinos are stable
their lifetimes are infinite because
like light there is nothing for them to
decay into
since it's impossible to collect enough
neutrinos to weigh them in a terrestrial
laboratory cosmologists use massive
galaxy clusters as their scales
sprinkled emits the luminous matter in
the clusters are innumerable neutrinos
their masses can be measured using
gravitational lensing a direct
consequence of einstein's general theory
of relativity
all matter dark and luminous
gravitationally deflects light
gravitational lensing rearranges photon
trajectories as eddington showed in the
famous 1919 total solar eclipse star
positions were displaced from where they
should have been due to the presence of
the sun's massive warping of space-time
the light that should have been there
was lens gravitationally the amount of
movement told us the mass of the lens in
this case the sun
what kind of light should we use to
weigh the poltergeist particle such as a
neutrino
there certainly aren't enough neutrinos
in our solar system to bend the sun's
light
the most promising source of all is the
oldest and most abundant light in the
cosmos the three kelvin cosmic microwave
background or cmb
these cosmic photons arose from the same
ancient cauldrons that produced the
neutrinos themselves that now ply the
universe today
the cmb is a type of cosmic wallpaper a
background against which all the mass of
all the matter in the foregoing
foreground clusters of galaxies
including neutrinos can be measured in
2015 the planck satellite showed
powerful evidence for the gravitational
lensing of the cmb using a technique
that is eventually guaranteed to detect
neutrino masses
this technique based on the cmb's
polarization properties will
dramatically improve in the future
thanks to a suite of experiments
deploying tens of thousands of detectors
cooled below one tenth of a kelvin at
the south pole and in the chilean
atacama desert neutrinos are the very
paradigm of dark matter they're massive
they get lensed and they interact at
least gravitationally all the required
properties of dark matter they don't
interact with light they are not the
dominant form of the cosmos missing
matter but they are the only form of
dark matter that we have honest to
goodness measurements about
after we measure the masses we can thin
the herd of potential dark matter
candidates just as there are many types
of ordinary matter particles ranging
from quarks to atoms we might expect
there are also several kinds of dark
matter perhaps there's a dark periodic
table
the hunt is on to directly detect dark
matter and several exciting upgrades to
liquid noble gas experiments are coming
online in the coming years
perhaps there will be detections but so
far the direct detection experiments
have only produced upper limits
in the end neutrinos might just be the
only form of dark matter we ever get to
see
the next century of general relativity
promises to be as exciting as the first
space-time tells matter how to move
matter tells space-time how to curve
said the famous john archibald wheeler
we've seen where the curvature is now we
just need to find out what's the matter
and where to look better for that lost
matter is where the dark is so what do
you think should we probe more and more
the properties of neutrinos the only
form of dark matter we know to exist or
keep searching for new types of
particles or maybe new forces of nature
responsible for gravity's deflection at
the larger scales in the cosmos leave a
comment below and let me know what you
think is the most promising avenue to
discover more about the mysteries of
dark matter